avec nous maintenant françois vincent
vice président québec à la fédération
canadienne de l'entreprise indépendante
beau soir en somme c'est fillon
votre réaction d'abord à cette décision
aujourd'hui du premier ministre
d'annuler les rassemblements à des os
dans les zones rouges principe agréable
pour personne entend les citoyens ont je
pense qu'on s'ennuie tous de se voir
peut-être que les commerçants il ya une
dose de stress de plus en baisse que ça
va diminuer les achats
parce que justement les gens vont pas se
rassembler puis si je pense là qu on
peut quand même célébrer noël on peut
quand même offrir des cadeaux à aux gens
de nos entourages
et justement pratiquer l'achat local
mais quand on regarde par exemple vous
avez un tableau de suivi de la santé des
pme sur votre site web
on voit que 62 % des pme au canada sont
complètement ouverte 29% ont des revenus
normaux présentement
quel sera l'impact de la décision
d'aujourd'hui vous pensez sur les
affaires des pme ccfa des décisions qui
vont avoir comme impact d'augmenter ces
chiffres la vie au québec on voit que
les chiffres ont réduit aussi quand on
regarde en septembre c'était 78% qui
était complètement ouverte on t'emm à
63% au niveau des revenus aussi c'était
40% qui avait des revenus normaux en
septembre c'est ça tombait à 30 % le
commerce de détail le kg actuellement on
vit les semaines les plus importantes
pour le commerce de détail ses 65 % des
commerces de détail qu'on peut retrouver
leurs ventes normales au canada mais
donc toute nouvelle mesure aura un
impact clairement sur l'économie et sur
la possibilité de ces entrepreneurs lot
voit un peu de lumière au bout du tunnel
mais voilà mai mais moins deux soupers
moins de rassemblements moins 2 en
déplacement tout ça c'est moins de vent
de toute façon pour l'ensemble des pme
aux présumés ces monnaies de vente
mais maintenant en tant que citoyen on
peut faire un effort supplémentaire
peut-être qu'ils vont avoir moins de
super mais on va quand même faire des
super temps construire et pas un petit
cadeau pour s'offrir un petit resto
comme ça on va pouvoir aider les
restaurants
car près de chez nous là les cadeaux on
peut en acheter chez nos commerçants pas
en afficher nos commerçants locaux une à
86% club des manières différentes pour
être capable justement de rejoindre la
clientèle
par exemple le ramassage en bordure de
rue la livraison sont accessibles en
ligne
donc ici en tant que citoyen là je pense
qu'on a parlé beaucoup des d'achat local
maintenant assez le temps de passer de
l'encouragement à l'action appui à aider
le maximum possible nos petits commerces
pour être capable de passer ces temps
difficiles qui jouent sur leur niveau
économique mais également sur leur moral
de façon assez important est-ce que
encore la majorité des ventes en ligne
se font sur amazon mais si on regarde
les revenus de d'amazon le canada il ya
eu une augmentation assez importante par
rapport au trimestre précédent
puis le confinement probablement pas
aidé ça parce que c'est le commerce de
détail on se le cachera pas et une
transition qui l'achat en ligne des jeux
avant confinement était prenait de plus
en plus d'importance maintenant pendant
deux mois les personnes ont peut-être eu
un habitude de faire un clic
puis ensuite d'études de retrouver la
boîte en avance chez eux puis comment
fonctionne le le marketing maintenant
c'est du marketing ciblé par rapport aux
recherches qu'on fait donc le
consommateur
ici ça peut être facile de voir dans
cette voie là mais c'est pas ça qui va
aider notre économie locale
est ce que la décision d'aujourd'hui
pourrait en même temps tourné à
l'avantagé des commerces parce qu'en
principe en zone rouge les restaurants
par exemple les bars sont fermés
jusqu'au 11 janvier lors si on n'arrête
pas mal tout petit a pas de rencontres
durant temps des fêtes est ce qu'on peut
encore avoir un espoir de faire baisser
fléchir cette courbe de deuxième vague
et de reprendre les activités au début
du mois de janvier ne bougent pas je
pense qu'on peut avoir espoir il à la
première slash chose que les
entrepreneurs veulent faire cesser
d'ouvrir leur commerce est de servir
leurs clients c'est de faire leur
passion vous avez bien et vous avez fait
des beaux textes là dessus si monsieur
fillion notamment sur la restauration il
ya une très grande incompréhension dans
certains secteurs d'activité économique
donc si on est capable justement de
baisser la coupe qui permettent à ces
commerces ledoux vrai
ça va être le plus beau cadeau qu'on
peut faire aux entrepreneurs puis on
voit que des bonnes nouvelles aussi
devant nous notamment en grande bretagne
où ils vont commencer avec le vaccin que
vous en avez parlé juste avant donc je
pense qu'ici je me permets de citer
renée martel un jour à la fois
mais maintenant on a tous à l'autre sans
que ça soit derrière nous parfait un
jour à la fois vous avez raison françois
versa merci beaucoup merci envoi